i've been following
a couple of youtube channels it's like
one of those things where one day
youtube algorithms recommend something
that they think i'll like and i go
into this rabbit hole and i've been
following these sailing videos and i see
these guys
on like a 53-foot sailboat just sailing
around the world they're doing like 90
000 miles sometimes they have a few
people on the boat sometimes they've got
10 and they kind of go to where the wind
takes them
and they just tend to try to avoid
hurricane season
they pluck a lot of their fish out of
the water um
how would how would somebody use the
nomad capitalist lifestyle or the
strategies that
you talk about often in a mobile sort of
environment where they don't actually
have
rooted real estate citizenship in one
country like
yeah well so the challenge is if you're
an american
that's going to be hard because the tax
exclusion for americans that at least
you know allows you to accept your
salary and that gets you out of the
system
for some of the savings the foreign
income exclusion uh
frowns on things like sailing if you're
international waters
uh they want you to be on land and so
i've had americans come to me who work
on yachts or they own
odds and and they have a very hard time
saving on taxes on their business
for everyone else uh what you'd want to
do is you want to have some place on
land that you've established
in a country here's my home here are my
utility bills here is my tax
residence my tax home so that in your
case for example canada
wouldn't come after you and say well
you're designing kind of like a long
vacation
i mean i think the tax authorities in a
lot of countries probably look at
sailing as kind of like a long vacation
rather than a home
uh they like you know and so does your
bank by the way or
your crypto exchange or whatever it is
that's doing kyc
they would really want to see you know
where is the home even if you're
not there you're out sailing
you